They are bitter rivals both gunning for America's top job.
And with weeks to go before their first face-to-face presidential debate,...
...the war of words between Barack Obama and his Republican challenger Mitt Romney is heating up.
This country does not succeed when only a very few do well.
We can't move forward if we've got leaders who write off half the nation,...
...calling them a bunch of victims,...
...who will never take responsibility for their lives.
I don't see a lot of victims here today.
His slogan, of course, is "Forward."
I think "Forewarned" is a better slogan for him.
I mean, we know where it heads.
We've seen this before.
We can see it here.
We can see it in Europe.
We have to get America working again.
We know how to make America work again.
He doesn't.